Hello.
My name is Choi Seung-hyun, also known as T.O.P, from South Korea.
I'm 35 years old.
I'm a magician, actor and art collector.
I'm so honored to be a crew member of the dearMoon space project.
I have always fantasized about space and the moon since I was young.
I applied to dearMoon because I want to feel new stimulation and enlightenment.
When I was told that I was chosen as a crew, I was so happy.
Well, nice to see you again.
Congratulations.
MZ has been like a brother to me over the years.
He's an entrepreneur and adventurer who I admire.
Also, MZ inspires me as an art collector and gives me a lot of advice for my life.
As a Korean citizen and artist,...
...I feel great pride and responsibility in becoming the first Korean civilian...
...going to the moon and representing my country.
For this project, I want to support my dearMoon crew members.
When I finally see the moon close up,...
...I look forward to my personal growth and returning to Earth...
...as an artist with new inspiration.